I have no idea y'all were together I
don't know private lives I never know
people's private lives and I literally
was like you and Rita or together I had
no idea I only know people's work I same
reaction most days I know I it's I know
I love her she's so talented and so
sweet yeah yeah got a good one anyway
well Welcome to our show I just moved
here to New York City do you like coming
here I love coming here um yeah it's uh
it's the Big Smoke it's the fast lane a
lot of people um my favorite thing is
food I love just to come here and eat
and great restaurants and uh and I just
go wandering the streets and just look
at people especially Christmas time yeah
I just love like any kind of holiday
time because it it lit up is like it
feels like you're in a movie well you
are in a movie A lot of times so you
probably feel that a lot yeah um well
you have two daughters right two
daughters yeah um y yep TK and mat
they're 11 and nine a I have a n yeah
that's me so this is behind the scenes
parting my knowledge and they're doing
great to pretend that they care I was
going to say are they interested though
cuz you take them on set right they are
interested they you know I think they I
mean I take they've been on all of the
sets of everything um they've been in
you know like a couple of little um
extra and Thor put my youngest daughter
in M where she um that was from that the
set of Thor and it was funny she said I
want to be in the film and then um she
didn't realize you had to work all day
and um we did like I think I did one or
two takes and she was in a scene with
Bale you know one of the greats of all
time and after two text she walked off
and came up to me she said okay give me
my
money I said no no darling you have to
keep doing this all day she said day
know your worth though know your
wor I've got two good takes of me now
pay me oh my God I love it is funny your
kids though they see what you do and
they think because my my kids have gone
with me to like award shows and they're
like so how so when are we leaving and
I'm like are you are you out of your
mind we look at these 10 minutes we'
been here 10 minutes and they're like
when can we get ice cream I'm like okay
cool um you just had you celebrated your
first anniversary right with and I've
been married for every year that's
amazing I heard there was an eldis
impersonator at your wedding is that was
that planned randomly an eldis
impersonator was there I didn't organize
that neither neither did Rita how is
there randomly look at how incredibly
hot she is that's amazing like how did
they randomly end up at your that's
that's amazing some I I've got a couple
of friends who like to do things like
that um fun and uh you know Ramy Malik
actually organized for a Freddy Mercury
impersonator at my birthday a year or
two before that and I thought it was I
was like why wouldn't you just do it
yourself that would have been way
funnier yeah like no we just wanted to
embarrass you I heard that she actually
proposed to you as well which is she
proposed to me I mean we do things
really Topsy Turvy um she proposed to me
you know she it was um she's great you
just don't say no to reader that's one
of them and um she's very powerful she
very powerful she approached me before
that when we first got together after a
couple of weeks she said we had dinner
and she said uh you know uh you know
when they people say they get together
and they say let's just take a slow and
see what happens and all that I was like
yeah yeah I know that one and she said
well we're not doing that just right off
the bat we're going all that's pretty
sexy that's very very sexy if it works
you know yeah it works it's working some
sort of then you're like crazy yeah it
worked out did she sign you up to do a
Shrek Airbnb yeah cuz I saw this footage
and it's incredible most of the great
and interesting things in my life is
because of Rita say she's very random I
love it she yeah she you an article came
out the Airbnb had made this Shrek
replica of the of Shrek's house in the
middle of Scotland like way out in the
middle of
nowhere and yeah you looks so creepy
everyone would think that we had a photo
you know camera crew and stuff that was
just us two driving to the middle of
nowhere she painted herself green she
revealed she had brought these costumes
and that we were getting
content oh my gosh and you were like I I
didn't realize this romantic trip was
about content I just I just love
picturing being romantic looking like
those characters being romantic yeah
that would that would be really hard for
me to to yeah to ignore yeah and our
accents our accents oh no we have your
accents let's hear your strik accent
here we go we got some
footage he who's this F I told you I
don't like
B oh don't mind him oh we old grum P
pants he's just an ogre he needs no
har told you talk about at that
woman oh
God I think my accent is better than my
accent is better than his sure
I am just say I'm G to say I can't get
away from the fact that y'all like I
really hope you made out in those
costumes there was no no way I could
with a big rubber
mask we did that and we like sat there
in these ridiculous outfits eating
dinner in a in Shrek's house and then
wash the paint off your face she like
okay well we did that now what LIF but
how funny is that I just love the
randomness of what a fun relationship
CLE goals I like it that was the look at
his new movie which he directed it's
called next goal wins so this is
actually an adaptation from a British
documentary right it's a true story yeah
they made a documentary about this in
2014 it's the true story of the worst
soccer team in the world and uh this
team from American somore in 2001 they
suffered the biggest defeat ever and
just to for some for some context the
team and the country have never up until
this point had never
won a game or scored a goal ever or
scored a goal scored a single goal and
they lost to Australia and this is still
the biggest record for biggest loss um
in an international game they lost to
Australia
310 now that would put most people often
deter you from you know ever wanting to
get on the pitch again but they pushed
through they work through it and they uh
and they just got up and literally
tighten their laces and uh and and they
got a new coach played by Michael F
Bender in the in the movie and this is
this sort of really lovely joyous
uplifting story of uh true story of
these underdogs who um who just wouldn't
quit yeah I love an Underdog Story is
that what kind of Drew you to do it yeah
yeah I mean I love underdogs I love you
know just exploring people on the
margins and yeah you know and I mean I
was always at school obviously very
popular um but um you know I was always
you know I always like take people under
my wing and maybe and in turn maybe it
was me being taken under their wing I
think like bringing people together in
some sort of Team situation is just like
forming a family you know you kind of
support each other and uh that's what I
loved about look after each other sports
is great for bringing people together
yeah Sports and theater all that kind of
stuff I loved as a kid because that's
where you find your your people yeah
yeah your friends and it's and it's s in
the Pacific Islands where I'm from and
it was a great opportunity for me to
come home and show indigenous people on
screen uh which is sort of my theme yeah
um I do that a lot and and you want to
see a shift in that representation yeah
I do CU like you know we just had a
really great show that my friend
Sterling harjo and I created called
reservation dogs which really well it's
a fantastic TV show um set on
reservation in um in Oklahoma and you
know my what what I want is for that to
be a common thing and a regular thing as
opposed to yeah cuz everyone's like wow
this is the first thing we've seen in
you last 10 years with you know native
representation I was like that's not
good yeah don't give that compliment
yeah yeah that's right yeah you don't
want the compliment you want it to be
more normalized yeah yeah and yeah and
just like tackling diversity without it
being tokenism and you know putting the
the stories into the hands of the people
who are from there yeah absolutely
because who better to tell it exactly um
I also love this about you because
obviously I love music um you're quite
the DJ on set I hear like you have
playlists I do have playlists I play a
lot of music on Fridays I let the crew
decide a little whiteboard and they come
and but it's so Random between the
different people on a crew like it's
really one of the worst radio stations
oh my God you would hate my Serious
Channel cuz that's what it is it's so
Random it will go from Frank Sinatra to
Nirvana yes it will go yeah I love that
though yeah that's how you like learn
great to include the team and like you I
mean the the crew who are the team um
yeah and and music I think you know as
we all know it just silence is just so
awkward and on set when you're sitting
and everyone's being very silent it's so
you feel like something's wrong and I
like just having music and fun and dance
and and just to a very mellow and uh
does the playlist affect like what's
going on do you ever make playlist
specifically for this day we're shooting
this so I well I think when um yeah when
there are various takes where the sound
doesn't matter um when the actors are
doing stuff I'll play certain things
like um you know the characters in a you
know coming in it's quite an intense
situation I might Play the soundtrack to
the shiny and um you know there's it's
like really tragic over the top really
melodramatic moment it might be that um
adio piece from Platoon oh my God I
don't know my God that's amazing um yeah
know or then ridiculous Sesame Street
Music whatever it is just to kind of
elevate the mood or like just get people
into it yeah um I heard that you do you
get injured before filming a lot is
thisa I pinched my neres I got that
pregnant once and that is when I was
pregnant I thought I was going to die
was it down one side down the whole left
side I had the same thing girl I wanted
to hurt someone I wanted them to feel
just for a second what I was feeling
it's unbearable I know if many of you
have experienced stica it is
debilitating it's just it's all you can
think about and then people talk to you
and you just want to hurt them and I'm
like I don't know why I want to hurt you
but I just I'm in such pain don't talk
to me I wanted to chop my leg off I was
like if that fixes it I'll do it yeah
just but I hear that this happens when
you film things you get my yeah it's
like the stress Manifest this your
superstitious thing you do just I need
to injure myself it will do well feel
pain when I'm creative very method um I
always get something wrong with me and
then it goes away as soon as I finished
oh my gosh there is a lot to unpack iny
all emotional so it's emotional okay so
I heard that maybe you're doing Star
Wars are you going to do a Star Wars on
yeah I've been developing that for a few
years with them but I think you know
with any film but that one in particular
it's something I'd really like to get
right so I don't want to rush it so um
yeah just going to Bubble along on the
side it's exciting yeah our family we
were Star Wars fans growing up so yeah
too I want to capture that you know that
joy and the entertainment of those early
ones that yeah like Empire TRS back and
Return of the Jedi and all those ones so
um I'm trying to figure that out and uh
all right take your time it'll happen
cuz you do it right when you do it so
take your time let's do another break
while you're taking your time uh Tao's
movie like that next goal wins is in
theaters now y'all got to check it
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y have have a great
night I'm going
home